shei and irving and his pics from last
week so Paulie did you a front row lost
to schoener Irving yeah we took Indiana
and Maryland covered big time okay for
Hyundai che got roughed up last week one
three and two he's now 23 22 and three
on the year but you won the bet with the
front row Shea what do you have this
week for the front row nothing holy do
you have a bed god what oh I've got one
okay all right here we go
what speaking of paulie's uh patriotism
that wrapped the flag around the boy
type of patriotism Army's plus six and a
half against Air Force I am an American
so I'm taking Army you're gonna have to
lay the points if you want to be an Air
Force kid I can't take that I like army
football too much can't do it I will not
do it he loves West Point I he does I
would have been disappointed Paulie
would have gone against my cadets well
we do have for you shades are I love
what boy you love West Point bar and
grill all right
we have Iowa getting ten and a half in
the first half against Iowa State
against Ohio State we're taking Iowa to
cover the first half ten and a half
points this is at Kinnick yes
guys minus 10 after an emotional barely
when did not cover game against the
blind Lions at the shoe damn it to hell
you're down to you only
that's our only option you're you only
Oh seat and I a hundred this would make
you even when you think by the way we
have che give me the rest of the picks
here for this weekend Texas State plus
nine and a half army plus six and a half
the
after minus one Ole Miss Plus for
Wyoming plus three and then I just added
Georgia State - three and a half let's
get it I we have an intern in here his
name is Adam Evans he's from Kansas and
he's a big fan he just wanted to say
hello he's a big fan of yours by the way
Jay so Adam if you would like to say
hello to who he calls you wheels I guess
because of your 10 500 meter - hey Shay
I was gonna buy thought you're gonna be
in studio but they said you might show
no that's a good person they should have
given you a chicken contract hey it was
the last time you went gopher hunting
Kansas never been y'all never shoot
prairie dog - no a lot of people in
Kansas they get drunk and shoot prairie
dogs or like a 17 hmaertl so you didn't
I've never done it it's popular out west
but thank you
Thank You Shane thank you thank you Adam
Adam Evans our intern for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]